ça y est on sert plus à rien c'est fini
c'est c'est has been c'est la faim ou
pas mais ça on en parle juste après
l'intro et salue les gens derrière
l'écran c'est françois pour la chaîne
explique moi encore je suis ravie comme
toujours de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle vidéo aujourd'hui on va traiter
d'un sujet de fond mais avant toute
chose je tiens bien entendu à dire que
déjà je m'inclus dans le lot des gens
dont je vais parler et à dire aussi que
j'ai un profond respect pour tous mes
confrères qui pratiquent le youtube film
making
on n'est pas là pour casser du sucre sur
le dos de qui que ce soit bien au
contraire
et d'ailleurs je vous mets en
descriptions une liste de chaînes comme
ça avec des gens qui raconte des trucs
hyper intéressant et il y en a plein
d'autres causes oublie sûrement donc
voila ce sera une liste non exhaustive
bon par contre je sais pas vous mais moi
cet été j'ai fait un petit point j'ai
fait un petit constat j'ai un petit peu
la sensation qu'on finit par tous être
un petit peu des clones les uns des
autres et dire un petit peu tous plus ou
moins la même chose pas de la même
manière et tout mais moi aujourd'hui
quand je vais sur youtube et que je
regarde des vidéastes que je regardais
il ya un ou deux ans eh ben je m'emmerde
un petit peu et j'en ai parlé un petit
peu à droite à gauche avec des
connaissances et et on a un petit peu
tous ce même ressenti donc est ce qu'on
n'est pas arrivé à une espèce de moments
charnières dans le youtube game sur les
vidéastes est-ce que c'est pas le moment
de faire autre chose ou de faire
différemment ou est-ce que c'est fini ça
on va en discuter dans cette vidéo on va
voir les choses sous plusieurs aspects
et 6 et de voir un petit peu
quelle est la réponse à cette question
et j'espère ne vexer personne parce que
c'est vraiment pas du tout du tout mon
intention
alors déjà le premier point qui donne un
petit peu cette sensation de redondance
et et du fait que on a l'impression un
petit peu con racontent tous la même
chose c est ce que tout a déjà été dit
est ce que tous les aspects du film
making ont été traités j'ai envie de
dire oui hein j'ai envie de dire oui
mais et pas par tout le monde et ça ça
change quand même beaucoup de choses
c'est à dire qu'un discours qui va être
hyper clair pour quelqu un parent
youtuber peut être complètement
incompréhensible pour une autre personne
et inversement un discours
incompréhensible pour quelqu'un m'a dit
autrement pour quelqu'un d'autre pas si
je suis claire mais ça peut être quand
même beaucoup plus compréhensible qu'on
a tous une façon d'expliquer les choses
et rentrent de présenter le travail
d'une façon différente et on est tous
différent aussi à regarder les vidéos on
apprend différemment donc le fait qu'ils
aient de la variété en soit même si les
sujets ont déjà été traités c'est pas
forcément une mauvaise chose
bon par contre je pense qu'on peut se
mettre d'accord sur le fait que les
vidéos sur le flou d'arrière-plan sur
les filtres end et sur les luttes su bon
là ya ce qu'il faut c'est plus la peine
d'en faire je pense mais il ya tout un
tas de sujets qui ont certes déjà je
pense été traité mais qui peuvent être
traitées sous un angle différent pour
amener encore plus de choses à vous le
viewer qui a gardé nos vidéos l'autre
point qui fait en sorte que la variété
bas et c'est plus trop trop ça au niveau
des youtuber film making
c'est ce que moi j'appelle la dictature
du birol merci daniel schiffer derrière
l'appellation il n'est pas hyper juste
maintenant birol on met ça à toutes les
sauces et ça veut plus dire grand chose
c'est le nouveau cinématiques machin qui
au départ était un petit plus pour
illustrer pour faire des belles images
et montrer un petit peu ce qu'on est en
train de faire c'est devenu une espèce
de passage obligé à tel point que ben
face caméra comme ça eh ben ça fait un
petit peu plat visuellement comparé à
d'autres mais surtout le plus de
dommages à mon sens c'est que le b roll
qui est du domaine de la forme et de
l'esthétisme a pris le pas sur le fond
c'est à dire que maintenant on est
tellement habitué à avoir des birol de
tarés et tout ça de machin que en fait
on attend le birol et puis finalement
s'il n'y a pas beaucoup de fond derrière
ci a pas beaucoup de sujets traités si
c'est pas un truc très important dans ce
programme il ya du breuil et savait que
petit à petit je pense sans le vouloir
aussi on s'est enfermé un petit peu dans
ces trucs là alors encore une fois je
fais pas de généralités on sait ce dont
je pas tout le monde mais c'est une
tendance globale et même moi je me dis
dès fois lire assez dommage
j'ai un truc intéressant à dire bon g
soit pas le temps de faire du pétrole
soit pas forcément la motivation parce
que je me dis que est ce que vraiment ça
va servir comme pour cette vidéo là où
je vous lui dites de suite il y aura
aucun birol puisque je vois pas
l'intérêt de mettre du bémol par dessus
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
donc au final moi je vous dis que cette
dictature du birol j'ai bien envie de
lui dire d'aller se faire bien et je
mettrai des bips parce que sinon on est
habitué des magnetic donc là aussi je me
dis qu'il ya des choses à faire ou du
coup à ne pas faire pour avoir un
contenu intéressant et qui puisse battre
utile aux joueurs donc à vous les amis
le troisième point qui est celui qui je
pense nous a le plus pénalisé et nous a
le plus fait partir dans quelque chose
d'un peu monotone ce sont les codes qui
viennent des états unis et du canada
là on va pas être hypocrite 1 on a tous
regardé les vidéos de peter mc kinnon
peter mc kinnon c'est le mec qui est au
top je dis pas que c'est le meilleur
mais c'est celui qui est le plus connu
celui que tout le monde regarde un petit
peu avec envie il faut dire ce qui est
parce que voilà il fait quand même de
très belles choses il est très fort y
voilà tout le tralala et puis il ya
toute sa clique de potes les canadiens
les américains et peut-être aux jets les
matières poya etc etc
et ça c'est pas nouveau et les us ils
ont toujours un petit peu donné la
tendance sur plein de domaines
artistiques même sur le cinéma en
arrière ça reste quand même la référence
populaire et a raison c'est des gens
talentueux et vraiment c'est une bonne
chose mais on s'est tellement gavés je
pense de tout ça nous est aussi les
joueurs qu'au final il ya une espèce de
normes qui s'est faite des codes
instauré par ces youtuber là qui font
que ben on s'est dit mais pour faire du
youtube il faut absolument qu'on
reprenne aussi ses codes sinon ça va pas
être bien et ça ça aussi c'est je pense
une grosse erreur et ça tue un petit peu
la créativité est encore une fois un je
m'inclus dans tout ça je fais une
autocritique
c'est pas juste en disant les autres ils
ont fait pas bien c'est leur faute non
non moi je suis aussi responsable que
tout le monde là dedans et et j'en ai
conscience et justement j'ai envie de
faire des choses qui font que l'on va
pouvoir évoluer et passer un petit un
petit step
du coup faut pas non plus être un
bisounours et se dire que allez je vais
péter tous les codes et je vais faire un
truc totalement original
et tout ça danse ça faut pas non plus
rêver il ya des bonnes choses dedans il
faut peut-être savoir faire le tri tu
savoir se détacher en fait de tout ça et
faire les choses un peu plus à
l'instinct peut-être et puis un autre
point aussi qui fait qu'on a tendance à
s'uniformiser énormément c'est tout
simplement les codes de youtube
d'ailleurs en parlant de code de youtube
et de passage obligé c'est un petit peu
le moment où je vous encourage à vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait
qu'yves et la cloche tout ça tout ça
parce que c'est cool ça fait ça fait
plaisir et puis ça aide la chaîne à se
développer
voilà c'était le c'était le moment code
de youtube respecter fring est coché oui
parce que youtube de parce qu'il est
tout simplement nous contraint dans les
formats le modèle économique bref on est
un petit peu obligé aussi d'avoir des
points clés qui reviennent
systématiquement si on veut que la
chaîne youtube fonctionne et si on veut
pouvoir s'en sortir et puis gagner un
petit peu sa vie avec et je suis pas en
train de faire le caliméro les règles du
jeu elles sont là on les suit on les
suit pas mais je me dis qu'il ya
peut-être une possibilité de suivre les
règles
ok mais les suivent de manière un peu
plus intelligente peut-être de les
détourner un petit peu peut-être de
faire en sorte qu' on ne se perdent pas
nous mêmes dans une uniformisation un
petit peu du format y quand on reste
quand même entre guillemets compétitif
c'est à dire visible référencés et tout
ça pour parce que parce que bon on fait
les vidéos pour qu'elle soit vue c'est
normal enfin sinon vrai pas de vidéo sur
youtube on ferait des vidéos chez nous
et on les laisserait est chez nous et ça
servirait pas à grand chose alors on
fait quoi
moi maintenant on a posé les bases des
problèmes entre guillemets ou des des
contraintes
qu'est ce qu'on fait alors pour les
autres je sais pas moi j'ai cette
sensation d'uniformisation mais
peut-être que les autres ne l'ont pas en
tout cas pour cette chaîne voilà ce que
moi j'ai envie de faire et ce que je
vous propose parce que cette chaîne elle
existe parce que je suis là mais elles
existent parce que vous êtes là aussi
donc c'est donnant donnant et je vous
encourage dans les commentaires en dire
ce que vous pensez de ces propositions
première chose je ne vais plus faire de
vidéos sponso sur la chaîne je vais
continuer mes prestations ferez sûrement
des choses ailleurs mais sur cette
chaîne il n'y aura aucune vidéos
sponsorisées à partir de maintenant et
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
peut-être ça changera peut-être ça
changera pourquoi et ben parce que ayant
découvert ça un petit peu
récemment je trouvais ça cool au début
parce que je me disais je vais me faire
payer pour un truc que j'aime bien faire
et parler d'un produit que j'aime bien
puisque je parle que des produits que
j'aime bien et au final ça me met mal à
l'aise je ne saurais pas vous dire
pourquoi j'ai toujours été honnête quand
il ya eu des vidéos sponsors et tous
mais je suis pas à l'aise avec ça et
rien que pour ça je me dis ça me tue un
petit peu mon envie de nous tuer ça me
met dans une case qui me convient pas
qui me plaît pas donc stop aux vidéos
sponsors si les marques veulent
m'envoyer des produits à tester
aucun souci ils peuvent les envoyer mais
vu que je serai pas payé déjà je suis
pas obligé de faire la vidéo 1
et puis je pourrais dire absolument tout
ce que je veux donc si on en voit un
truc vraiment vraiment merdique pourrait
dire c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
merdique dans ce choix là il ya vraiment
une liberté qui fait que ça me plaît ça
me donne envie
et puis j'ai mon taf de vidéastes à côté
de piedmont vrai métier au final et puis
je préfère vous proposer des packs de
lutte des prêts cette déformation
d'ailleurs il y en a une qui arrive au
mois de novembre là je suis en train de
voir ça va arriver vite que vous avez le
choix d'acheter ou pas mais au moins
c'est des choses que moi j'ai fait c'est
des produits que je sais que j'ai fait
du début à la fin et je sais ce que ça
vaut et je sais qu'il n'ya pas
d'entourloupe je préfère gagner ma vie
sur youtube comme ça plutôt qu'avec des
vidéos sponsors le deuxième point que je
vais changer ses stops oberoi à outrance
c'est à dire que si j'ai envie de vous
faire une vidéo fasse calmes comme ça
aujourd'hui sans rien par dessus sans
aucun voilà artifices juste vous et moi
on discute et ben je vais le faire je me
sentirais plus mal de le faire parce que
je le faisais avant mais je me disais
voit quand même les gens qui vont se
dire tu t'es pas fait chier et ou machin
mais mais c'est pas question de pas se
faire chier c'est que le but de cette
chaîne il est de partager et des fois
c'est juste vous et moi on discute enfin
je discutais vous me répondrez dans les
commentaires et puis voilà et d'ailleurs
je vous encourage à venir sur le
discorde parce qu'il ya une communauté
extraordinaire où il ya beaucoup dé
change donc le lien est dans la
description venez faire un tour sur le
discorde c'est vraiment un super endroit
enfin la dernière chose c'est que je
vais refaire passer mon job de vidéastes
en premier
avec le confinement et tout c'est vrai
que baye avait que youtube à faire donc
je me suis mis à fond forcément puisque
sinon c'est un peu chez et puis ça a
marché on a passé les 50000 j'ai eu
plein de propositions de deux vidéos
sponsor de machin je me suis dit ah ça y
est je suis youtuber et tous et non non
je ne veux pas être youtuber en fait je
veux juste être vidéaste et ça c'est mon
petit plaisir et je veux que ça reste
mon petit plaisir taf en premier et
youtube
c'est cool youtube c'est cool mais c'est
en seconde donc pour répondre à la
question est ce la fin des films et
choeurs sur youtube je pense qu
absolument pas on a encore plein de
choses à découvrir à partager à échanger
vain de nouvelles techniques plein de
nouvelles astuces plein de nouvelles
réflexions je pense qu'on a tous pleins
de choses à apporter encore et si vous
êtes d'accord avec ça bien vous savez ce
qu'il faut faire c'est le coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo si
vous n'êtes pas encore abonné à cette
chaîne est bien c'est le moment où
cliquer sur le petit bouton s'abonner
activer la cloche tout ça tout ça et
puis moi je vous dis les amis rester
curieux et à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo de mouches de m je vais
de quatre ans pour tout ce qui était au
top race la mouchetée gens je lui ai mis
sa race puis amy st